et en direct dont ce jt en direct de
metz didier big secrétaire général de
force ouvrière senti bonjour didier
vereecke merci de répondre à nos
questions ce matin sur rtl france dans
un communiqué force ouvrière
votre syndicat évoque je cite un
compromis acceptable
laurent berger le secrétaire général de
la cfdt a dit ça fait 2000 196 euros de
plus par an il y a des moments où il
faut conclure vous jugez avoir obtenu
gain de cause
vous savez comme bonjour
comme dans toute négociation il y à des
contreparties on vient avec la cahier de
revendications et en repart avec un
compromis nous nous avons consulté
l'ensemble de nos syndicats il décide
que ce compromis est acceptable
c'est une une après une première date à
prendre voilà avec des moyens financiers
mais de ségur
ça n'est pas seulement les finances pour
les personnels et des augmentations de
salaires le segura d'autres piliers le
nombre de lits la gouvernance des
hôpitaux tout cela il faudra le mettre
sur la table dans les prochaines
semaines pour que nous puissions
d'avancé sur d'autres dossiers
mais dans un premier temps nous avons
estimé que les avancées du gouvernement
sont acceptables dont dans l'état sur
notre antenne la semaine dernière vous
disiez vous appeliez à une hausse
salariale de 300 euros par mois pour une
enveloppe totale selon vos propres mots
de 9,8 milliards d'euros au final c'est
une hausse de 183 euros en deux temps
pour les personnels médicaux et para
médicaux et non médicaux pour un budget
de 7 5 milliards d'euros
pourquoi avoir cédé alors nous n'avons
pas cédé sur les 300 euros
nous nous sommes retrouvés dans une
négociation et dans cette négociation
chaque fois que nous avons baissé nos
prétentions
nous avons obtenu d'autres compensations
parce que tout le monde ne voit que ce
protocole par le biais des 180 euros
alors qu'il y a à l'intérieur de ce
protocole énormément d'autres points qui
vont ramener de l'argent aux personnels
hospitaliers
nous avons par exemple tenu une
augmentation des promotions de grade
nous avons obtenu la catégorie b pour
les aides soignants et la catégorie a
pour les infirmiers ce sont des avancées
qui vont aussi avoir mécaniquement des
avancées financière pour les agents la
cgt et sud
quatre autres organisations a également
appel à une journée d'action nationale
pour mardi on sera le 14 juillet est ce
que le front syndical est divisée non
depuis le début nous avions dit à sud et
à la cgt que le 14 juillet c'était la
fête nationale qu'il fallait pas
mélanger les choses
nous avions aussi dit à l'époque les
agents hospitaliers avaient besoin
d'avoir des vacances et pouvoir
récupérer s'il devait y avoir un rebond
dont peu vide et que le 14 juillet
n'était peut-être pas une bonne date
pour pouvoir relancer un mouvement
d'autant qu'au moment où ce 14 juillet a
été décidé nous ne savions pas si nous
allions signer ou pas le c ur puisque
cette date a été décidée aux alentours
du 16 donc vous voyez que c'était bien
notamment des résultats du ségur
vous venez de d'évoquer un éventuel
rebond la crise sanitaire de la crise
épidémique jean castex a appelé vendredi
à porter le masque pour se prémunir
d'une éventuelle deuxième vague
si deuxième vague il ya le secteur
hospitalier sera-t-il suffisamment
préparés alors je pense que au niveau
matériel le gouvernement aura pris les
leçons de ce qui s'est passé sur la la
première vague de la pandémie
après les personnels vous savez on nous
a présentés comme étant des héros nous
n'avons fait que notre travail nous
sommes des fonctionnaires et à ce titre
là nous avons des droits mais nous avons
aussi des devoirs et ses devoirs c'est
le prendre en charge la population et
tous mes collègues l'ont fait avec eux
avec le plus grand sérieux et en se
mettant à la disposition des français
c'est notre métier c'est notre mission
est donc s'il devait y avoir une
deuxième une deuxième match que je
n'espère pas bien sûr que le système
hospitalier sera là après nous verrons
comment les choses seront traitées mais
on en est pas encore là et on espère
bien sûr pour l'ensemble des français
que la gestion de la pandémie ciel
devait revenir sur une deuxième forme
ce frais d'une autre manière et nous
permettrait de pouvoir mieux la gérer et
surtout en protégeant beaucoup plus les
personnels protéger les personnels c'est
important il ya une déclaration ce matin
chez nos confrères d'europe 1 du
président de l'association des maires de
guyane
david richer qui dit je cite nos
soignants n'ont toujours pas de masque
il alerte jean castex qui seront en
guyane votre avis par rapport à cela il
ya encore une pénurie de max de masques
en secteur hospitalier
côté c'est cet étonnant cet étonnant
c'est au gouvernement de prendre les
mesures pour protéger les agents
hospitaliers nous voulons bien faire le
travail qui est le nôtre mais nous
n'acceptons pas de le faire comme ça a
été le cas à beaucoup d'endroits au
début de la pandémie sans les moyens
donc là c'est de la responsabilité du
gouvernement
moi je le mets en garde nous avons nous
déjà déposé plainte au parquet de paris
un pur plat une teinte contre x parce
que c'est inadmissible que l'on puisse
demander à des agents de devoir
travailler dans des risques aussi
important sans qu'ils soient protégés
donc je mets en garde le gouvernement
par rapport à cela il faut absolument
que nous ayons l'ensemble des moyens à
notre disposition pour pouvoir nous
protéger et faire notre travail sans
mettant en danger bien sûr les agents
mais aussi toute leur famille parce que
lorsqu'ils rentrent à leur domicile et
bien leur famille et leur famille et
sont présentes et il est hors de
question qu'on puisse accepter cela donc
il est important que le gouvernement
travaille je vais me rapprocher de la
guyane pour savoir ce qui se passe
exactement et nous interviendrons bien
sûr directement auprès du premier
ministre nous le rencontrons demain par
rapport à la signature du protocole
donc je m'entretiendrai avec huille
directement de slam demain dernière
question didier gehrig après le cmh et
le yen ph le snam hp a donné hier
annoncé hier qu'il donnait aussi son feu
vert pour la hausse de 450 millions
d'euros prévus pour la rémunération des
médecins hospitaliers cette fois votre
position
écoutez les médecins ont négocié
eux-mêmes avec monsieur vers en dentaire
du ségur
je sais que les négociations étaient
très âpre très difficile les médecins
avaient des prétentions importante
je pense pour certaines justifié parce
qu'il faut retrouver de l'attractivité
pour les médecins dans le service public
donc la négociation a eu lieu certains
syndicats ont raté donc cette position
j'espère que les avancées seront à la
hauteur des enjeux
mais les médecins sont tous de grands
garçons il
ils ont fait des négociations comme nous
donc je pense que si certains ont signé
c'est que pour eux et pour leurs bases
les négociations ont été à la hauteur
des enjeux maintenant je sais que
certaines grandes centrales n'étaient
pas présentes avaient claqué la porte
donc ceci est quand même un signe de
fragilité de l'accord et il faudra le
voir dans les semaines qui vont venir
merci didier mérite d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
le secrétaire général de force ouvrière
santé